mientras los casos de kobe 19 aumentan
en todo el mundo francia confía en
reforzar su campaña de vacunación que
ahora se ha ampliado e incluye a los
niños
hoy abrimos nuestra campaña de
vacunación para incluir a los niños es
oficial he recibido la aprobación de
nuestras autoridades sanitarias y
científicas tenemos que tomarnos en
serio la vacunación de los niños en las
próximas horas se podrá pedir cita en
línea para la vacunación de los niños de
5 a 11 años la que trigo o fósforo o
rovérsio psuv en israel los infantes de
5 a 11 años ya pueden vacunarse desde el
mes pasado y pueden hacerlo directamente
en su recinto escolar
fue bastante rápido y me siento bien me
la puse para poder recibir el pase
sanitario
allí ya se han vacunado más de 100.000
niños de esas edades hasta ahora la
vacuna ha demostrado ser segura para ese
grupo de edad según los expertos en
salud
hemos visto que la vacunación no causa
daños se registran menos efectos
secundarios que en los adultos
en los ensayos clínicos pzifer y bayonne
tec comprobaron que su vacuna contra el
virus tiene una eficacia del 97 por
ciento en la prevención del contagio
sintomático en menores de 5 11 años
desde estados unidos el gobierno de
vaivén afirma que más de 5 millones de
infantes ya han recibido dosis de facer
desde que fue recomendada por las
autoridades sanitarias el mes pasado en
el resto del mundo varios países de
américa latina- emiratos árabes unidos y
china son algunas de las naciones que
también han comenzado la campaña de
inoculación para los niños